can we look at a neuron
yeah you say that prediction happens in
the neuron what does that mean
so neuron traditionally seen as the
basic element of the the brain
so we i mentioned this earlier that
prediction was our research agenda
yeah we said okay um how does the brain
make a prediction like
i i'm about to grab this water bottle
and my brain is predicting what i'm
going to feel
on all my parts of my fingers if i felt
something really odd on any part here i
notice it
so my brain is predicting what it's
going to feel as i grab this thing
so what is that how does that manifest
itself in neural tissue right
we got brains made of neurons and
there's chemicals and there's neurons
and there's spikes and the connect you
know
where where is the prediction going on
and one argument could be that well when
i'm predicting something
um a neuron must be firing in advance
it's like okay this neuron represents
what you're going to feel and it's
firing it's sending a spike
and certainly that happens to some
extent but our predictions are so
ubiquitous
that we're making so many of them which
we're totally unaware of just the vast
majority we have no idea that you're
doing this
um that it there wasn't really
we were trying to figure how could this
be where where is these where are these
happening
right and i won't walk you through the
whole story unless you
insist upon it but we came to the
realization
that pretty most of your predictions are
occurring inside
individual neurons especially these the
most common are in the pyramidal cells
and there are there's a property of
neurons
we everyone knows or most people know
that a neuron is a cell and it has this
spike called an action potential and it
sends information but we now know that
there's these spikes internal to the
neuron
they're called dendritic spikes they
travel along the branches of
the neuron and they don't leave the
neuron they're just internal only
there's far more dendritic spikes than
there are action potentials
far more they're happening all the time
and
what we came to understand that those
dendritic spikes the ones that occurring
are actually a form of prediction
they're telling the neuron the neuron is
saying
i expect that i might become active
shortly
and that internal so the internal spike
is a way of saying
you're gonna you might be generating
external spikes soon
i predicted you're going to become
active and and we we've
we've we wrote a paper 2016 which
explained and
how this manifests itself in neural
tissue
and how it is that this all works
together but
the vast ma we think it's there's a lot
of evidence supporting it
so we that's where we think that most of
these predictions are internal that's
why you can't
be they're internally neuron you can't
perceive them
from understanding the the prediction
mechanism of a single neuron
do you think there's deep insights to be
gained about the prediction
capabilities of the many brains within
the bigger brain and the brain oh yeah
yeah yeah
so having a prediction side of the
individual neuron is not that useful
you know what so what um the way it
manifests itself
in neural tissue is that
when a neuron a neuron emits these
spikes or a very singular type of event
if a neuron is predicting that it's
going to be active it makes it spike
very a little bit sooner just a few
milliseconds sooner than it would have
otherwise it's like
i give the analogy in the book it's like
a sprinter on a on a starting blocks in
a race
and if someone says get ready set you
get up and you're ready to go
and then when your race starts you get a
little bit earlier start so that it's
that
that ready set is like the prediction
and the neuron's like ready to go
quicker
and what happens is when you have a
whole bunch of neurons together
and they're all getting these inputs the
ones that are in the predictive state
the ones that are
anticipating to become active if they do
become active they they happen sooner
they disable everything else and it
leads to different representations in
the brain so
you have to it's not isolated just to
the neuron the prediction occurs within
the neuron
but the network behavior changes so what
happens under different predictions
different inputs have different
representations so how i
what i predict um is going to be
different under different contexts
you know what my input will be is
different under different context so
this is this is a
key little theory how this works
you